hey guys I hope you're ready for lesson
number two where we're going to learn a
lot more about the foundational concepts
of AI and machine learning so let's get
started so what exactly are we going to
cover in lesson number two so what we're
talking about is the history and
fundamentals of AI and data
science this will include a brief
history of AI we're going to explain AI
in the simplest possible terms um and
talk about how it's evolved over history
and how it's grown into what it is
today I'm going to clarify some
definitions relating to AI so what you
often hear is words used interchangeably
people talk about machine learning
they'll talk about AI there's a lot of
these common misconceptions so what I'm
going to do is go through the
definitions and explain exactly what
these different terms
mean I'm then going to introduce
foundational AI Technologies so this is
the deeper part of the tech stack which
is actually powering your apps like chat
GPT Google
Gemini um any banking apps you use uh
Facebook uh Instagram anything like this
uses some foundational AI Technologies
um within them so I'm going to explain
what these foundational Technologies
are and then going to explain um
although it won't be the focus of this
course I'm going to explain about how
you actually train and deploy AI models
so this will be um perhaps for a future
course actually doing this but I'm going
to explain how people train the AI
models as
well so let's get started on this slide
you see the simplest possible
explanation for an what AI really is and
that is you take a known input and you
have a known output the part which is AI
is what happens uh in terms of linking
the two together so your known input
could be anything it could be in the
case of something very simple for you to
relate to could be the weather it could
be um how many clouds are in the sky on
that day the known output could be how
much rain has fallen on that day let's
say you have lots of data lots of days
where you've done this measurement and
you want to link the two you want to
link what's the percentage cover of
clouds in the sky to how much rainfall
is likely to happen that day we can do
that using an AI approach so we can use
um essentially what AI is is function
approximation we can approximate some
form of link between these two um these
two uh observed
phenomenon this can be very very
powerful um because it can link things
which perhaps we didn't even know a
linked um they can find patterns between
them so this is essentially what the
simplest definition of AI and machine
learning let's compare this though to
other forms of computer science like
coding like python coding for example
how does this differ so I would argue
that a an AI approach is very very
different to a programming approach so
an AI approach here is simply function
function approximation you have your
known data your known output data and
you're trying to approximate the
function programming is very different
to this we essentially have to hardcode
rules um
with an AI approach the rules kind of
form themselves that's the the
generation of the AI is creating the
rules from the known input and known
output with programming we have to do
this ourselves we have to either think
uh how are these things related and
decide beforehand using some maths
approach perhaps um uh and we have to
code these rules ourselves so if you
take this example here this is some code
basically saying um if a variable is
less seven let's print a success message
the value is less than seven it's like
let's say within the limit if it's uh
between seven and N it's going to print
a warning it's almost over the limit
let's say um and here we can see that
the limit is 10 so if it's greater than
10 we're going to print a fail message
so here we're having to code out this
set of rules um or function to actually
check something with an AI approach we
don't have to know what these Vari
variable would be uh beforehand
necessarily we can let the this uh AI
training actually generate these sets of
rules let's say or this pattern
itself next we're talking about a quick
history of AI and the key thing here is
it's much older than many people
realize AI algorithms are essentially
mathematical constructs they they're
mathematical projections domains
functions Transformations it's all
essentially just numbers
and initially many of these foundational
uh layers which we use today were laid
down by scientists in the 1800s people
were actually doing this work on paper
um and they weren't really able to truly
verify if uh you know this would work uh
the scale we're using it today but these
foundational building BLX were thought
through and developed by people going
back in the 1800s so much older than
most people
realize but what we had was no computing
power to actually demonstrate and to put
these and uh put these into practice and
apply these uh mathematical
formula however in the 1900s what
actually happened was um we started to
develop things like simulations horis
STS things like Monti Carlo Theory you
will have heard of I'm sure um lots of
this was developed but again yeah had no
computing power to really prove any of
this would work in uh
practice what then happened was was
something which I guess um at the time
people thought was the right decision
but what actually happened was we ended
up leaving behind many of the uh study
of neural networks um and they were kind
of left on the curb and there's a lot of
focus more on simulation and horis sixs
which is a different different science
think of Monte Carlo Theory um it there
was a lot of emphasis on that and people
thought that neural networks weren't
really the
future but then what happened was there
was a breakthrough in a method known as
propagation which we'll talk about a
little bit later uh leading to some of
these different chat Bots essentially
early chat Bots being developed Alex net
being one in
2012 uh all the way through to chat GPT
so what happened was there was like kind
of Renaissance of uh neural network
research science and uh Bank propagation
was sort of like the key part of uh in
1986 which really um spurred that
research to kickstar again and uh this
like laid the building block for what CH
PT is today which is I guess the most
famous AI app people are familiar
with in terms of the timeline so the key
thing here is we've got all the way to
this crazy stage today where large
language models are passing our
University entrance exams which is
completely wild um but what we have is
looking back through the history we have
things starting with simulation Theory
and hor istics which I was saying uh
were happening a long time ago uh
leading through to then early chat Bots
like Eliza robotics were then one of the
next sort of like key um areas of
research and then neural networks with
these becoming progressively more and
more powerful as time goes by leading up
to what we have
today but why is it that AI is becoming
increasingly powerful so what we have
here is a chart that's known as Moors
law and this is the theory that every um
every two years the number of
transistors on a microchip doubles
number of transistors is linked to the
computing power of any micro chip what
you see on the chart here is years as
the x-axis and transistor count as the Y
AIS uh each point you see on the chart
is a different microchip and the key
thing to see here is that this is a log
chart so this is exponential increase in
computing power what this is basically
meant is that um lots of the computers
we have now are much more capable than
the computers they have before and
they're able to prove lots of these
theories and lots of the science which
we weren't able to demonstrate or put
into practice before combined with this
we also have gpus gpus um are originally
developed for gaming actually um and
what they found now is that they out
perform significantly CPUs when it comes
to AI applications for um reasons we
won't really go into in this
presentation but they become they
they're cheaper more accessible and
companies like Nvidia have grown into
these huge uh huge companies today based
on them producing gpus which power um
which can perform AI training
significantly faster than
CPUs we've also seen things like new
programming languages becoming
um available uh programming Library
sorry things like tensor flow pytorch
these really open up the possibilities
of training AI models to lots more
people make it a lot more accessible and
easy for people to get started with AI
model
training it's also possible nowadays to
even deploy um and execute uh neural
networks on these Edge devices things
like the mobile phones web browsers um
it can AI models can be set up to run on
security cameras uh so they're becoming
more and more lean and um flexible so
people can deploy them uh on not the
super computers but on just these Edge
devices which don't have that much
memory so we're really seeing a lot of
breakthroughs happening and it's all
sort of coalescing in the past couple of
years and that's why we're seeing so
many breakthroughs happening recently
it's because all of these combining
factors and meaning that the science
we're able to apply it a lot more in the
the real
world this is a slide to just show how
people can get involved in AI so
typically um if you imagine you're a
civil engineer let's say if you were
previously a general engineer and after
a few years on your um University degree
maybe after the second year you have to
decide which discipline you want to go
into you could think of AI as being
something a bit similar to that and that
you have different bands you have
perhaps like the of chemical engineering
civil mechanical industrial um you could
pick one discipline that you actually
really want to focus on because these
can be quite different and quite unique
and you want to become a kind of expert
in one uh perhaps um because they can go
really deep into these subjects So
within AI we have something quite
similar where we have different schools
of thought so we'll actually start with
the bottom one which is the school of
like Vision intelligence the way you can
think of this this is basically around
um these different strands being perhaps
different aspects of something similar
to human human intelligence but we
replicate it in a machine so Vision
intelligence is things like image
recognition Machine Vision object
detection this is where a computer is
able to identify and pick out images uh
pick out objects from uh images or
video you have the school of Robotics
which is a sort of combination of both
Hardware sensor technology and uh also
perhaps actually a coalesence of like
all of these different schools of uh um
AI research uh robotics kind of combines
lots of them planning scheduling
optimization this is quite an important
one in construction actually and there's
some startups that are doing um some
very interesting stuff around this this
is around finding like critical path
analysis understanding um how long
things could take what different options
are you have expert systems which is
actually taking things like processes
like let's say you want to become um
like in some cases these can be
hardcoded as well different rule sets
for actually becoming very good at one
specific task so if you imagine an
expert system could exist for like
medical practices where if a patient's
temperature is over a certain degree if
they have a certain um observed symptom
if they have another sort of certain
observe symptom it will eventually
through rules-based uh systems it will
eventually predict what perhaps their
diagnosis could be so you have expert
systems for lots of different
applications speech is quite interesting
so you have speech to text and also text
to speech um this is some technology
that could power like real time
translations for example um and cut down
the latency in terms of so a lot of um
resources are being spent at the moment
in terms of trying to cut down the
latency of doing speech to text and text
to speech so you can get this real time
interactions with uh chat Bots through
speech feel very seamless NLP is um a
lot around uh classification clustering
so you can imagine sentiment analysis
being one of these where you take a
sentence is it positive is it negative
is it Angry is it sad something like
this you also have information
extraction so this could be things like
identifying key personal personal
identifying information within um text
and removing it so anonymizing um or
classifying information automatically
redacting information this is some use
cases for NLP from information
extraction and then you have machine
learning which is essentially like some
form of function approximation like we
were discussing earlier so uh within
this you have deep learning Predictive
Analytics which I'll discuss a little
bit more later in this
presentation but what really is AI and
uh I guess why do so many companies have
ai in their name even when they don't
seem to be obvious ai ai
apps so let's talk about what we really
mean by data science Ai and machine
learning so you often hear these
different terms used interchangeably so
what we aim to do here is actually like
clarify some of these definitions so
when you talk about the whole subject
you actually talk about data science
this doesn't just include function
approximation model um like AI model
training all of this stuff it actually
includes how you handle the data how you
prepare data how you structure it all of
this is included in the subject of data
science so this is the overarching
subject so if you wanted to study this
at University you might choose a course
in data
science uh AI actually sits within data
science and its most high level
definition could just be you could say
that this is a non-natural construct
that can make a decision without human
intervention the idea here is that your
system doesn't require human to be
actually involved in the loop so you
have a computer which can exhibit some
human uh um humanlike decision- making
abilities but without a human actually
being involved so this is the most high
level decision uh high level Definition
of artificial intelligence sits within
data
science however machine learning is just
one approach to creating AI uh
algorithms it's just one approach so
there are other methods that exist
things like basian uh methods which is
kind of different to machine learning
but so machine learning is just one
strand of AI so it sits again within the
world of AI so when you talk about uh
machine learning just keep that in mind
it's one field let's say of
AI so yeah Bas and networks is another
one that exists a very easy one perhaps
you for people to understand which is
will have used a lot of in engineering
would be like uh linearly squares um uh
squared uh regression so linear
regression essentially which is just
like a line of best fit through
data we also have methods like um deep
learning so those sit within um
artificial artificial intelligence and
machine learning and um these are
essentially just uh neural networks that
have more than two layers so that's the
definition of deep learning it's just
more advanced neural
network and artificial neural networks
are just generic function function
approximators so this is like the most
highlevel uh definitions um but when you
hear people using them sometimes you'll
hear people talking about it
interchangeably so here's how you
understand it gets like narrower and
narrower and how the the the subjects um
sort of sit within each other
so neural networks are one such
technology that can be used to build fun
function approximators and we're going
to talk a little bit more about those
here so the key thing here is as I was
mentioning before around back
propagation but we actually have before
that loss functions feed forward stage
and um then back propagation the key
thing to think about here in terms of
how neural networks work is that you
have different neurons and different
connectors what you do when you're
training the model is you send uh you
take your base input data you send it
through to the output and then what you
essentially do at the end of that
process is you back propagate and send
um information back through to adjust
the weights and measure this loss
function what you want to do is try to
minimize this Lo loss function you see
in the chart here in order to better
match your output data
uh to your data that you actually want
to do the comparison against so you have
input data coming in you have your
output data coming from your model and
you're doing like a comparison to some
other data some other observed data with
a similar pattern so what you want to do
here is try to minimize that loss
function and what you're doing is um
adjusting the weights of the different
elements which are connecting between
these different neurons to better sort
of handle the data and reduce the loss
in
accuracy the most simple way I could
possibly explain
it but how do we actually make these so
what you do is if you want to create a
certain AI Model A Certain neural
network let's say for a certain task um
what you have to do is think about what
the actual application is because some
technologies will be better suited to
some applications than others so you
want to try to use the best form of
Technology for solving that specific
problem um so and what you have on the
chart here is a summary of some of the
most common different um AI models which
could be considered or AI Technologies
if you want to solve a problem so I'll
just talk through these briefly so at
the start of this section I said about
why do why are there so many companies
that say about using AI but it's not so
obvious what they're doing a lot of um
although it's changing more a lot more
in recent years but previously
a lot of AI was around um more on the
machine classical machine learning side
so this would be things like linear
regression you see in the chart there um
decision trees is another one so this is
all classical machine learning doesn't
mean to say that it's like any less
Advanced some of this is super super
sophisticated and complicated um but
most of AI in the past has been more
like this classical um classical machine
learning
then what you have is um so so you could
perhaps use classical machine learning
for something like predicting uh future
data so taking things like Trends stock
market prices something like this and
trying to predict Trends or future
patterns so this could be one such use
case but there's many um for deep neural
networks so these typically power text
to speech so this is where you're typing
into let's say some form of translation
tool and it's coming out with a um
speech so Google Translate for example
Vision intelligence this is um one that
we've been doing a lot of with civil's
AI and this is um this is powered by
convolutional neural networks this is
also used for things like self-driving
um is a convolutional neural network
problem so companies like Tesla um you
know spend so much money on training
these convolutional neural networks for
self-driving so cnns are called um
recurrent neural networks this is again
another one for text to speech but
slightly different to deep neural
networks um Transformer models these are
used for predicting tokens so taking
we'll talk a lot more about these in the
next lesson actually but um Transformers
are essentially for token prediction so
taking a sentence predicting what the
next word might be or what the next
letter might be in a
sentence uh graphical neuron networks
these are used for recommendations so if
you're using something like Spotify or
Netflix and you watch a certain movie uh
your algorithm will recommend you your
next piece of uh content or your next uh
song or video um I believe this is also
what you know what social networks like
uh Tik Tok use I think it's graphical
neural
networks uh so these are the addictive
ones Auto encoders um this is also form
for recommendations um which again might
be one that gets used by some of the
social media apps and generative models
so these have become very popular
recently things like stable diffusion
for image uh generation so we're going
to be using some of those later uh in
our practical sessions along with the
Transformer
models so the decision lots of data
scientists have is around which uh
network type or which technology do they
use when they're actually building the
uh foundational models so they'll have
this will be the decision they have to
make which one are they going to use
maybe they'll change after they've been
uh working with it for a while they'll
also try a different type of model so
this could be quite
common and in terms of training so uh
real life AI model training so one of
the things which is often overlooked is
actually like how hard it is to gather
the data and structure the data a lot of
the data scientists you might speak to
will actually stress that this is the
data preparation data handling is
actually one of the most difficult or
challenging parts of building the AI
models so this can be really expensive
you have to perhaps pay people uh real
people to do the data labeling adding
bounding boxes onto things annotations
so it can be a really big uh kind of
operations task to get all of these
people to label all this data you need
for your AI models so this is a big
limiting factor actually in terms of AI
model training it's just data
preparation you then have the training
stage which we've already talked about
so this is in terms of like minimizing
the loss function back propagation blah
blah blah things like this um then you
have to actually package this into a
solution so you have to like maybe
containerize your AI model and you have
to allow uh inference like model
inferencing so how do people actually
send data into the AI model how do they
get it back out this is known as the
school of like or the the process of AI
model
inference uh you then have to validate
test you know make sure uh the solutions
actually working performing uh so you'd
have a big testing stage perhaps where
you're doing some measuring of how it's
How Your solution is performing you have
to deploy it so this could be on the
cloud you could host it on some a
company like AWS Google Cloud uh or you
could try and host or you could host it
locally and this would involve you
having to get a server make sure that
you have enough memory on the server
make sure uh the memor is uh sufficient
for the number of users coming so this
is all very complicated actually um
making sure it doesn't crash uh so we've
had some you know experiences and
challenges around um some of this stuff
with civil's AI and then monitoring and
potentially retraining so something that
often gets overlooked is that you have
to constantly retrain some AI models and
you know companies like track GP uh
companies like open AI for example in
these uh images you see below track GPT
cost 2 to 12 million per training cycle
for their larger models so each time
they want to do this and retrain it try
and make it better $2 to 12 million it's
really expensive so this comes down to
the costs you need really expensive
computers to to basically retrain the AI
models and they have to run for quite a
long time so yeah this makes it quite
inaccessible actually for training for
the more building foundational
Technologies which is one of the reasons
why in this course we're not going to
focus too much on the training maybe
we'll do that in another course but in
this one we're not going to talk much
about building foundational models we're
going to talk more about using
them and for the final part of this for
this lesson what I really want to stress
here is actually that many of us in
engineering um and construction already
using some foundational aspects of
machine learning so what you see here is
a chart linking um this is actually for
tunneling linking uh Cavern size to and
crack information to basically how long
it will stand up for and so this is one
example but you see there's many charts
that we use in construction for
predicting things um you call it
empirical data so um what what we're
saying here is that whenever anyone says
to you in construction I don't trust AI
I don't use AI um keep it away from me
what you should actually remind them of
is that they're probably already using
all these foundational aspects of U
machine learning and AI in their daily
work because they use TRS like this the
only difference here is that I think
this was drawn the lines of best fit
that you use were drawn by an auor uh
rather than a machine learning model but
you know in many cases machine learning
models can do a even better job uh than
humans at labeling this stuff and
creating lines of best fit so so you
should remind them of this okay congrats
guys you've reached the end of lesson
number two uh in the next lesson we're
going to be doing some really exciting
stuff we're going to be building things
we're going to be building AI agents
using no code tools so hope you're
looking forward to that one and see you
next time